luca lts kurz ausgesetzt könne nur
wiederholen
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute
wieder jump aber es ist kein schönes
gehört schon leicht von geräusche im
hintergrund
wir spielen heute nämlich wieder eine
neue folge luca sagt und luca dort
wieder vier möglichkeiten wie ihr das
leben in jobs zu machen
aus irgendeinem grund aus bisschen lag
über mir aber das passt auf jeden fall
denkbar dass vier gelegenheiten luca
sieht übrigens zu eurer information was
ich hier spiele nebenbei auch teamviewer
auf jeden fall sid luca was ich mache
und vielleicht deswegen team wie ein
bisschen länger du hast vier
gelegenheiten ich habe ich jetzt schon
eine genannte mal gesagt ja ich glaube
dass mit dem eingreifen werde ich mich
manchmal reichten bis aus also luca kann
theoretisch theoretisch leute ist müsst
ihr auch wissen auch steuern was ich
hier mache also hat die möglichkeit hier
das werde ich auch diese folgen denken
also deine challenge und zwar mal
meist wird eine komplette rüstung
erstmal weg machte aber das gehört dazu
die kosten ist ja auch genommen hast nur
in sachen dann gold sachen den einheiten
ich denke ich habe ich geschossen
das muss das eigentlich auch der neue
tiguan hat ist genau die auch noch
ziemlich gar keine rüstung komplettes
ende jetzt rüstung findest und sie
anziehst darfst du die nicht wieder
ändern gegen eine bessere rüstung ganz
okay alles klar also du darfst jetzt
nicht einen leder help findest und den
anziehst aber dann in der nächsten
kisten eisen elm haben sie eine eigene
liga an und du musst der brüstung hast
findet muss direkt also du wieder
anziehen oder sie nicht anders im
endeffekt nicht alles ein inventar
lagern
ok also wenn ich rauskomme muss ich
sofort anziehen wenn ich sie
herausnehmen oder ok alles klar
ganz normal an einem sonntagabend beginn
so nach drei sekunden schon alles klar
ich begriffen aber gute changes habe ich
schon genesis drin und das macht das
nichts aus alles klar
luca hat noch zwei luca sagt optionen
ich habe ich ein ufo
o
ja ich mag nicht zocken
ok muss ich nehmen muss ich nehmen
gut das ist gar nicht so schlecht gerade
wir haben eine halbwegs ordentliche
richtung können wir kurz mitte mai soll
alles klar
okay aber man minecraft sagt 120 fps
aber mein bildschirm lag wegen der
übertragung sagt ich verstehe nicht wie
man bildschirm lenken kann aber hey kopf
hoch es sehr schön förster das team
geschafft das ist das ding hier ist
bisschen tricky dann auch endlich hat
gar nicht eingreifen bei dir
okay da habe ich vielleicht erklärt dass
wir noch mal schauen wir haben sich
nicht verändert so warte warte warte
warte nein die namen eisen brust habe
ich nicht mehr nehmen das ist besser als
das sehr gut ich habe aber ich nehme
alles klar dass mir auch verboten modul
nimmt dann wünsche ich jetzt mal die
maus kann es steuert dann versuche ich
einfach mein glück
ich habe gott oh gott ich bin ein
lebenswerk
ich habe echt krass aber ihr seht das
nicht
ich glaube immer wenn ich selbst was
will befehl eingeben
roberto schlecht die sache 15 fps meist
ein schmerz weg was was bittet man sagt
ja meist ein schwert blue card esl trat
kurz ausgesetzt kann nur wiederholen
sein schwert weg ja und direkt hinter
mir ist eine junge fast nicht töten
nein das ist die einzige regel des
verboten leute schreibt man in die
kommentare
findet ihr dass es eine idee aus der
mann format passen kann wenn ihr denkt
ja schreibt es in die kommentare
wer denkt nein schreibt blut in die
kommentare postet
ich weiß ich weiß ich bin einfach nur
verzweifelt gerade eine schöne
kombination
ich wollte luca fragen ob er lud fan ist
er wissen die kommentare geschrieben in
die kommentare
alles klar in die kommentare von diesem
ein paar fragezeichen weil war das weil
es so unklar so eingeklappten wieder
frei ist der look von oder warte ich
unterhalte mich mit dem man eingespielt
oder luciano
kentsch toulouse ich bin krank ich war
gut
die wollen alle ja ohne witz muss immer
leute die wollen mich alle wegen meiner
der bootsmann was ist das für eine runde
kann ich ihn rausnehmen bitte ja ja du
hast keine luca sagt jawohl ich ja leute
ich bin vollauf vollbart heute wartet
dass mein konvention partner schreibt
einfach nur fragezeichen
wir reden gar nicht mehr übrig dürfen
er schreibt gutshot meine gefühle für
dich sind kennt ja oder nein
er hat mich auch noch getötet das meinte
ich mache schluss genau das meinte ich
hatte es ist vorbei jetzt nicht wieder
spielen sondern das was zuvor eine
kleine ja gut sagt sagen wir okay leute
vorbei ist auf das video nicht dank alu
zusammen vorbei sein und ihr schatten
die reiten jd und oft ein pferd wo es so
schön auf schatten fällt hier ist hirsch
mache jetzt einfach eine minute lang
jetzt einfach hier mit ich weiß was ich
mache haha deine schuld ich rede einfach
mit schatten fällt eine minute lang das
ist keine strafe
hey schatten hat mich so auf die reihe
nicht liebt ein
durch und dann kann es sein werden ich
habe mit seinem behinderten youtuber ich
weiß nicht vielleicht mit dem aufnehmen
hörig zu was ist ein können nicht zu
hören nicht zu auch wenn du uns verlässt
wir jetzt jedoch nutzt du kannst
schlafen und ich kann der brust ein